A talkgroup is a channel that does not
exist — and it is the thing you actually
listen to on a trunked system.
On a trunked system, "Police Dispatch" is
not a frequency.
It is a number — a talkgroup ID — naming a
group of users.
When a member keys up, the system borrows
a physical channel for that one call.
The next call from the same group may land
somewhere completely different.
Watch what that means over a minute of
traffic: call one lands on channel 3, call
two on channel 7, call three on channel 2.
The frequency changes every time.
The talkgroup number never does.
The group is the stable identity; the
frequency is a detail the system handles
underneath.
Every radio is programmed with the
talkgroups it can select and monitor.
Key up on one, and your radio sends a
request carrying that talkgroup ID.
The control channel grants a voice channel
and announces the talkgroup, so every
radio affiliated to the group retunes
together and hears the same call —
wherever it landed.
The IDs are numeric and system-specific.
On P25 a talkgroup ID is a sixteen-bit
value scoped to the system's identity; DMR
numbers its own way.
Hobbyist databases publish alias tables
that map the raw numbers to human names —
police districts, fire, EMS, public works
— which is how a scanner display turns
"talkgroup 101" into something readable.
Alongside the talkgroup rides a second
number: the radio ID of the individual
transmitting radio.
Together they answer the two questions a
listener has about every call — which
group is this, and which unit is talking.
Group identity for the many; unit identity
for the one.
Groups come in flavors.
Dispatch groups carry a desk's steady
traffic; tactical groups are short-lived
channels stood up for an incident.
A dispatcher can patch several talkgroups
together so they temporarily hear one
another, and an announcement group reaches
every subordinate group at once.
This is why every serious trunking scanner
— GopherTrunk included — is organized
around talkgroups, not frequencies.
You build allow lists and priority lists
of groups; each active call shows its
talkgroup ID, its alias, and the
transmitting radio ID; and the activity
log counts traffic per group.
The system hops frequencies constantly.
You never have to care.
So: a talkgroup is a virtual channel — a
number naming a group of users.
Its calls hop across physical frequencies,
but the ID stays put, which is why you
follow talkgroups and let the system worry
about frequencies.
Full write-up linked below.